the genome browser contains tracks that
we can use to visualize regions of the
DNA that are transcribed into RNA this
type of data can provide strong
supporting evidence to the hypothesis
that a certain region of a genome codes
for a gene let's look into the RNA seek
tracks section of the genome browser to
visualize this type of data we are once
again using the July 2014
gene assembly of dimalanta gaster and
focusing on can take one the RNA seek
tracks section contains results from
sequencing mRNAs and then mapping these
sequencing reads against the genome
hence regions with RNA seek read
coverage usually correspond to regions
in the genome that are being transcribed
to visualize the RNA seek read coverage
data click on the RNA seek coverage link
under the RNA seek track section to open
another window in order to specify the
settings for this track change the
display mode to full change the data
view scaling field to use vertical
viewing range setting and change the max
field under the vertical viewing range
section 237 unselect the adult males
track under the List subtract section
and then click Submit
by unselecting the adult males option
the genome browser will only show the
RNA seek read coverage from the adult
female sample if we did not unselect the
adult males option the default would be
to display both the female and male data
as two separate sub tracks on the genome
browser in addition to RNA seek coverage
it is often also helpful to consider
splice Junction prediction data that are
derived from the subset of RNA seek
reads that span two or more exons known
as spliced RNA seek reads to visualize
these predictions click on the exon
junctions link under the RNA seek tracks
section use the drop-down menu to select
pack and then click Submit we can
examine the splice Junction predictions
more carefully by zooming in to the
5-prime and 3-prime end of the exon
several other tools can help us analyze
splice junctions top-hat is a program
that can identify splice junctions
without relying on a database of known
junctions top-hat first identifies
potential exons by mapping segments of
RNA seek reads to the genome because RNA
secrets are short sequences derived from
processed mature mrna they will often
align continuously with an exon however
some RNA secrets will span multiple
exons thus containing valuable
information about splice sites top hat
builds a database of possible splice
junctions followed by mapping the actual
sequencing reads against these predicted
junctions this method allows us to find
novel splice sites aligns RNA secrets to
the genome assembly and then analyzes
the mapping results to identify the
splice junctions between exons
to illustrate let's view the RNA seek
data for a different Drosophila species
click on the genomes link on the main
menu bar to return to the genome browser
gateway page change the genome field to
D by armed appease the assembly field to
April 2013 BCM - hg s c / d bia
underscore 2.0 enter try - PA
into the search term field and then
click Submit we are now navigating to
the genomic region that contains the
presumed tri ortholog in the drosophila
by armed appease whole genome assembly
and will examine the evidence tracks for
the presumed ortholog scroll down to the
RNA seek track section and then change
the display mode for the modding code
top-hat junctions track to pack to view
the individual splice junctions after
clicking refresh we now see a single
track with a collection of all top hat
splice junction predictions from the
mixed embryos adult female and adult
male samples in order to create this
track splice junction predictions from
the different libraries are filtered and
then merged together the predictions are
color-coded to indicate the number of
spliced RNA reads that support the
predicted splice junction red indicates
that there are more than 1000 spliced
RNA seek reads supporting the junction
followed by brown pink green blue and
black in descending order with black
corresponding to fewer than 10 reads
several other evidence tracks are
available under the RNA seek tracks
section you may click on the track title
link above the display mode drop-down
lists to learn more about how that
evidence track was created and the
display convention used by that
particular track